und es sind worte voller hass hass auf
die politik hass auf die medien und hass
auf juden und mehrere auf mehreren
seiten hat claudia barner die mutter des
attentäters von halle festgehalten wie
sie auf die welt und die tat ihres
sohnes blickt ermittler fanden in der
wohnung von claudia ballett einen
abschiedsbrief sie schrieb darin dieser
starter mich und stephan so im stich
gelassen und weiter er hatte eine gute
seele sie haben ihn mit zerstört
vergisst das nie sie sind gefährlich
gestern wurde dieser brief dann vor
gericht vorgelesen und heute sollten die
eltern des haller attentäter sich vor
gericht äußern
den ganzen prozess verfolgt für uns mit
jörg völkerling der mir noch live
zugeschaltet ist ja kann denn die eltern
von stephan barth heute vor gericht
ausgesagt
drin ist war am ende nur ein wirklich
kurzes intermezzo von 15 minuten
nacheinander kamen vater mutter und
tochter in den saal und sagte sie machen
von ihrem recht auf zeugnis verweigerung
der tochter stand das bis zuletzt auf
der kippe
sie war auch diejenige die am
deutlichsten die zeichen ihrer abneigung
gegen ihren bruder zur schau getragen
hat sie verschränkt die arme vor der
brust
sie schaute ihn nicht ein einziges mal
an und sie sagte auch ihren ex-freund
dass sie ihn nicht mehr im gefängnis
besuchen weil es seinen anblick nicht
mehr ertragen
wir haben heute trotzdem einiges gelernt
über das innenleben in der familie
ballet im widersprechend dem
abschiedsbrief hat claudia ballett im
krankenhaus einer freundin anvertraut
dass sie sich von ihrem sohn belogen
betrogen und verraten fühlen nicht mehr
leben wolle
die war dann zwei monate im krankenhaus
in behandlung nach dem selbstmordversuch
und hat danach ihren beruf als
ethiklehrerin niedergelegt obwohl auch
beschrieben wurde dass sie eigentlich
überhaupt keine keinen hass gegen
minderheiten in der schule gelebt hat
sie hat auch den sehr wenigen
flüchtlingen helbraer versucht eine hand
zu reichen und auch die schwächeren
immer zu fördern
heute gab es trotzdem andere aussagen
von lehrerin was kannst du uns dazu
sagen ja heute bei fast der erste tag wo
stephan pariert mal nur zum zuhören
verdammt war und er hat sich
wahrscheinlich
gefreut über die schilderungen zwei
lehrerinnen haben beschrieben was für
ein aufgewecktes kerlchen eigentlich
stefan ballier in der grundschulzeit
noch gewesen sein sie haben das daran
festgemacht dass er zum beispiel bei
einer nachtwanderung wenn die mädchen
sich vor den kröten geekelt hätten dass
er dann gesagt hat sein die sind wichtig
oder dass er in der vierten klasse schon
gewusst habe dass insekten kerb tiere
seien die lehrerin haben geschrieben er
sei den anderen immer voraus gewesen
aber was ihm zu schaffen machte war
seine kleinwüchsigkeit er sei also
damals schon außenseiter gewesen disco
das wollte er nicht in den arm genommen
werden getröstet werden das wollte er
auch nicht
und später bei der bundeswehr hat auch
ein stuben kamerad ausgesagt gehört er
auch wieder zu denen die etwas in der
hierarchie weit unten standen sein spind
wurde aufgebrochen sein spiegel
beschmiert er hat sich aber auch selbst
das leben schwer gemacht den man sich
mit vorgesetzten anderer und anlegte und
seine schuhe nicht ordentlich putz der
das sei beim und eine todsünde gewesen
sagte der kamera